for sure
that's just who he is you know we've
seen it uh we've seen it a bunch in this
league with him him and I have had our
personal battles for years
quite frankly I've been busting his ass
for years
playoffs regular season
I was a high job with me today
I guess I'll do something like that and
you know that's there's no place in that
in the game and you know protect
yourself at the end of the day but uh
this has been growing for years
me with with me with other guys in the
league you all see it you know it's not
something that this is this isn't new
and I was just the end of it but
it's tough when you can't guard somebody
and can't do something with somebody you
got to resort to that that's what he's
done to a lot of players you know I off
the top of my head I think it's like
Damon and stuff he you know you know
it's just one of those things that's
what you resort to and that's cool but
um I'm glad my guys held it down tonight
and
have my back you know you know
throughout the whole thing